bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 3 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
accompagnés de nos invités mais aussi
des journalistes de la rédaction on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
dans le cadre de la journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
nous verrons les actions menées au
château de versailles et nous
reviendrons sur les annonces du
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier sur le sujet un nouveau
directeur pour le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bugue jarreau
est l'invité de cette édition
il nous dira comment il entend
développer le site qui peine toujours à
organiser de grands rendez vous
culturels
et puis on sport notre chronique du
jeudi consacrée aujourd'hui au rugby le
club de chevreuse affrontera ce dimanche
le point avec un des entraîneurs de
chevreuse stéphane douchez et à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
des personnes en situation de handicap
le président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier a visité ce matin le foyer
d'accueil médicalisé de limay malgré les
83 établissements présents sur le
territoire 165 adultes handicapés des
yvelines sont accueillis au sein
d'établissements belge pour répondre à
ce manque de place le département
propose la création d'un foyer d'accueil
médicalisé inter départementale
le point avec williams elle sephora
namani et jérémy quesada lutter contre
l'exil du handicap c'est l'objectif
annoncé par pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental dans les yvelines
les 83 établissements pour personnes en
situation de handicap accueille cinq
mille personnes un nombre pourtant pas
assez conséquent comparé à la demande
165 yvelinois sont en exil il ya de
l'exil volontaire et involontaire
nous avons choisi avec nos amis des
départements voisins hauts de seine et
val d'oise de regrouper nos forces pour
construire un établissement pour pouvoir
accueillir effectivement ces exilés s'il
souhaite revenir en france
en visite ce matin au foyer d'accueil
médicalisé de limay pierre bédier à
échanger avec les acteurs du monde du
handicap sur ce manque de place
obligeant ces personnes à se rendre en
belgique
pour la directrice de l'établissement le
problème viendrait de la non
planification des pouvoirs publics et du
nom recensement des personnes en
situation de handicap
concernant les personnes handicapées
nous recevons régulièrement des dossiers
de demandes d'admission qui nous
parviennent de familles qui
souhaiteraient avoir leurs proches à
proximité de leur domicile
et malheureusement du fait que nous ne
sommes déjà complets nous ne pouvons pas
donner de suite favorable à ces demandes
là pour assurer un meilleur
accompagnement des personnes en
situation de handicap psychique
un appel à projets a été lancé par le
département et l' agence régionale de la
santé d'île de france pour la création
de trois plateformes de services est
allé sur trois départements et pour
lutter contre l'exil du handicap le
conseil départemental insiste sur le
projet de créer un foyer d'accueil
médicalisé inter départemental afin
d'augmenter la capacité d'accueil en
établissement est à noter que début 2016
à follainville dennemont la première
résidence d'accueil des yvelines composé
de 30 logements permettra d'accueillir
des personnes handicapées atteintes de
troubles psychiques suffisamment
autonome pour vivant en logement
privatif et toujours dans le cadre de la
journée du handicap le château de
versailles a organisé une semaine
complète est dédié aux personnes en
situation de handicap
depuis le 24 novembre des visites et
activités spécifiques ont été proposé
une programmation spéciale est adapté en
fonction du type de handicap comme cette
visite théâtralisée sensorielle destinée
aux malvoyants où le spectateur est
amené à redécouvrir la sphère du collier
de la reine en faisant appel à tous ses
sens un reportage signé william l
c'est un acte là c'est l'arrêt dominent
les grands appartements
c'est là que nous allons évoluer parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous allez être les
auditeurs des auditrices les spectateurs
et spectatrices d'une visite spectacle
conçu gel et le colis de l'ariège
aujourd'hui nul besoin de lumière au
château de versailles
c'est une pièce théâtralisée sensoriel à
laquelle ces personnes malvoyantes sont
venus assister pour une immersion totale
la visite commence par une partie
exposition c'est à dire que les gens
vont au départ toucher les costumes dans
un premier temps et ensuite comme ça ils
savent exactement ce qu'ils ont devant
eux
et puis c'est formidable parce que très
souvent on dit on a toujours envie de
touche ont dit non non non vous ne
touchez pas où vous toucher avec les
yeux mais pas avec les mains voila et là
bas non là on peut vraiment toucher les
choses la pièce commence et tous les
sens du public sont en éveil
ici pas de convention sans sel ni décor
les comédiens se déplace au milieu des
spectateurs ont lésé florent tout ça
dans une autre fruit de l'amour et non
la raison tu fasses une princesse je
suis une bataille on est dans une
immersion totale et à une identification
complète avec avec l'action c'est-à-dire
l'action est autour de nous on est
presque témoins huit témoins privilégiés
au coeur d'une action
une pièce qui s'articule autour de
quatre saynètes qui raconte l'histoire
du vol du collier de la reine
les trois comédiens jouent puis laisse
place entre chaque scène un conférencier
poser comme narrateur de l'histoire
je suis en support
dans le récit et dans la précision ou la
confirmation d'un certain nombre de
faits des dates de lieux qui aident à
nourrir
l'intrigué surtout sa compréhension pour
cette pièce le château de versailles a
même réalisé une copie conforme du
collier de la reine pour que le public
puisse profiter pleinement de tous les
éléments du spectacle
l'autre possibilité c'est de sentir par
exemple sentir ce que pourrait être le
parfum de marc antoine est
ou alors possibilité aussi dans un
moment particulier où une dégustation de
café se sentir une odeur de café
on a l'impression d'être dans l'action
quand on est en haut c'est très
important parce que là tous les sens
sont en exergue donc s'il sait pas c'est
vraiment très bien dans le château ça
nous donne une dimension historique est
vraiment formidable et ma chienne a
participé elle était au coeur de
l'action la baie réagit aussi des
contraintes de mise en scène qui pousse
à trouver de nouvelles solutions mais
ici pas besoin de soleil au château pour
que la troupe plonge les auditeurs dans
l'atmosphère de l'époque
autre sujet à présent mercredi soir
avait lieu la rentrée solennelle de la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de saint quentin en yvelines
cette tradition annuelle depuis 2003
récompense les meilleurs élèves de
chaque promotion
cette année ils étaient une trentaine de
major à recevoir leur prix pour
l'occasion un invité de marque s'est
déplacé mireille delmas marty du collège
de france était la marraine de cette
rentrée solennelle
sandrine clavel doyen de la faculté de
droit et sciences politiques nous a
parlé de cette cérémonie écoutez la
c'est un moment où à la fois nous
recevons un invité un invité de renom
qui fait il ya un discours cette année
c'est le professeur mireille delmas
marty de l'institut du voyage de france
qui va nous parler du sujet le droit
peut-il humaniser la mondialisation
beaucoup nous ont écrit pour nous dire à
quel point il appréciait le fait d'être
mis à l'honneur et d'avoir le sentiment
d'être soutenus par leurs facultés
donc oui je crois qu'on peut dire que
c'est important et dans notre entretien
de ce soir nous recevons hugues jarreau
nouveau directeur général du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors vous venez de
prendre vos fonctions à la tête du
vélodrome qui a été inaugurée donc en
janvier 2014
il fêtera donc bientôt ses deux ans il a
déjà accueilli les championnats de
france et les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste
alors vous venez d'arriver sur un projet
complété car le vélo de route nationale
peine à trouver son public
oui c'est clair ces équipements est
magnifique en fait mais malheureusement
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on n'a pas réussi à
développer comme il fallait en fait
l'attractivité aujourd'hui on a eu d un
bel événement qui était le champion du
monde mais on n'a pas réussi à capter
acquérir à capitaliser sur cet événement
en fait et aujourd'hui on l'a dit
station principale de l'événement
séquelles du bâtiment c'est que l'accès
le vélo il faut qu'on puisse faire d
être plus d'événements avec la
fédération de cyclisme qu'on développe
plus de critérium de six jours
éventuellement ceux qui existent avant
dans le passé lié sa avec de
l'hospitalité faire venir des
partenaires et en plus de ça
l'équipement permet de faire aussi
d'autres choses
on a il ya quinze jours en fait on a
fait une humaine comme comme une
compétition de judo il faut développer
ses activités
l'équipement est fait pour être
multifonctions avait réglé c'est un
vélodrome cette destination principale
mais c'est également un espace où on
peut faire du judo du ping pong du
tennis toutes ces choses là donc nous on
va essayer de revenir faire revenir en
fait les fédérations dans cet espace
leur faire visiter leur montrer
l'attractivité le fait que c'est un bel
équipement on peut se garer facilement
et lille et on a une vue
comment facilement sur sur tous les
objets faciles surtout sur toute la
scène centrale
et en plus de cela en fait il faut aussi
qu'on développe la partie culturelle
là c'est un vrai défi parce que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en fait il ya eu un concert
qui est légal et demi je crois ce
week-end on a le comment le le téléthon
qui va venir avec un premier concert
avec un musicien qui à sanseverino
on essaye que l'on vous voyez vous
espérez que les gens vont venir et voir
ce bâtiment vivre autrement
l'idée en fait c'est que le vélo est
vraiment important mais il faut pouvoir
le développer faire en sorte que les
activités permanentes et qu'on puisse
vraiment faire en sorte que ce soit pour
la région pour le département et pour la
communauté d'agglomération un vrai outil
pour n'utilise son pansement fait ce qui
est compliqué en fait c'est la notoriété
en fait les gens même je pense que les
gens dans la région ne connaissent pas
ce bâtiment fatigué dans un lieu
magnifique en fait juste à côté de
commandes de la doller de loisirs en
fête qui est juste à côté en fait donc
lieu lui est vraiment agréable
l'équipement est tout neuf il n'est
quasiment pas utilisée donc aujourd'hui
font vraiment le relancer allez
expliquer aux fédérations
on peut l'utiliser pour autre chose que
du vélo développer clamart 100% le vélo
et espérait accueillir des commandes et
des artistes dans ce bâtiment en fait
les artistes aiment le vélo ou pas
d'ailleurs
pascal juste et on voit la mise à part
le vélo est appelé les événements
sportifs levée dont il peine quand même
attiré du monde
nous avons justement demandé à
quelques-uns des saint quentinois c'est
qu'ils attendaient de cette structure
regarder bas peut-être qu'il y ait de
grands champions qui gagne pour parler
de 50 heures une nouvelle qui va
s'étendre plus car ils o drom
très franchement je ne sais pas moi je
n'y suis jamais allé je pense pas y
aller d'ailleurs tant que c'est du vélo
je ne m'intéresse pas donc je n'irai pas
maintenant si autre chose pourquoi par
d'autres sports wii mieux puisque je
crois qu'il ya la place au centre pour
faire d'autres supports
le cyclisme mais aussi d'autres
événements qui soit chez soir les
publicités oui je pense en fait voyager
beaucoup d'efforts ont été faits pour
les championnats du monde c'était
vraiment une vraie vitrine et on aurait
dû continuer à capitaliser sur ces sur
cette vitrine
aujourd'hui on espère pouvoir accueillir
d'autres grands championnats des
championnats d'europe et aussi de façon
récurrente de championnat de france
iliad est un peu compliqué à mettre en
place avec la fédération de tennis et de
commandes de ces caisses qui doit aussi
elle faire profiter en fait des
championnats de france dans toute la
france donc ça peut pas être tout le
temps à ça quand on est venu en fait
mais c'est vrai qu'à terme ce serait
bien qu'on puisse accueillir fréquemment
tous les deux ans ce type de choses et
puis des événements aussi en dehors de
ce fait les athlètes sont quand même
disponible
on fait des séminaires pour les
entreprises ont fait des séances
d'initiation à la dame qui a dit qu'il
voudrait jamais venu en fait faut quand
même qu'elle laisse avec la vienne ce
qui est des séances d'initiation on peut
avec avec commander des moniteurs des
mêmes des professionnels peuvent venir
vous expliquer comment ça fonctionne et
c'est toujours intéressant qu'il n'ya
pas que le le comment la piste centrale
est aussi à côté une aire de bmx qui est
choqué aussi importante qui est
homologuée pour faire des compétitions
on a déjà les appuyer des championnats
de france de bmx
il faut aussi développer cette activité
pour les jeunes c'est plutôt fun ça ça
permet de commencer à pas mal
d'activités à côté en parallèle mais ces
règlements on entend vélodrome
les gens pensent tout de suite à vélo
est ce que il ya vraiment les capacités
pour accueillir d'autres événements
sportifs ont dû juno mais parfois c'est
pas l'installation n'était pas optimal
pour d'autres pas si si on peut
accueillir tout le monde enfin si on
peut accueillir après la mise en place
c'était un peu compliqué ça prendra
quelques jours de montage non pour
accueillir les tennis on pouvait lire du
basket du handball du tennis de table m
de l' escalade en fait on peut on peut
nous donner monter des murs ya pas de
raison de la lutte par exemple des
sports de combat et j'ai eu de la boxe
qui est venu en fait et on peut vraiment
accueillir tout le monde et après sur le
spectacle on peut accueillir soit des
petites scènes avec par des humoristes
on pourrait faire uniquement l'air
centrale avec 1500 personnes face aux
assises où 2000 personnes debout sur des
concerts un peu plus important et on
peut monter en fait à 4004 1500
personnes pour des concerts plus
important en fait donc on va essayer
d'aller convaincre les producteurs
d'aller convaincre les fédérations que
cet outil important et en plus dans le
cadre de la candidature 2024 en fait il
faut le faire connaître parce que c'est
vraiment lui inventer des projets par
rapport à d'autres championnats
internationaux en fait on travaille en
partenariat avec les fédérations de
cyclisme d'autres d'autres comme
d'autres championnats de france le judo
est venu pour des championnats régionaux
en fait mais on espère pouvoir les
accueillir sur dérange audition du
championnat en fait nationaux et c'est
aussi important je crois qu'ils ont été
satisfaits de l'accueil moi j'étais pas
encore en poste mais je
je suis passé quand même sur l'événement
il paraissait satisfait donc il faut les
encourager et puis des championnats de
france juniors d entre seniors tout ceci
un match de fed cup pourquoi pas et on
peut toujours rêver on peut aussi
accueillir un match de coupe davis on
peut toujours rêver en fait après à nous
d'aller les kovac moi j'ai travaillé en
fait un grand établissement était
maintenant l'accord hôtel arena en fait
une ancienne remercie et j'ai été en
contact avec ces personnes là en fait
donc je vais retourner les voir pour
essayer de leur expliquer qu'on peut
faire d'autre événement après on aura on
aura un aspect concurrentiel en essayant
de les attirer en faisant des prix plus
intéressants pour tout savoir coûte pas
trop cher par contre nous ce qui est
important c'est qu'on ait ça nous prive
pas non plus d'argent que ce soit à
cause de rentable pour tout le monde en
fait voilà c'est ça c'est vraiment
patent c'est la population locale qui
est visé l'île assez de ressources de
population si on peut le dire pour faire
pour lui je pense aujourd'hui notre
cible c'est vraiment le le département
la région tout au tout en fait on va pas
aller concurrencer les salles de
spectacle de paris elles sont très
nombreuses et les gens m'ont pas
beaucoup ne vont pas comment venir de
paris pour venir voir un spectacle à
saint quentin à moins qu' une
exclusivité je le souhaite mais ce n'est
pas le cas par contre pour des
championnats du monde les gens vont
venir 6 et je me demande de cyclistes
urbains d'europe on peut attirer la
population parisienne mais déjà dans le
bassin de population de l'oqali à tous
quoi faire il apprécie mais c'est celle
ci pour éviter aux gens de prendre la
voiture de prendre des bouchons et
d'aller sur paris de pouvoir leur offrir
à côté de chez eux une salle est
important pour des concerts importants
ou des événements sportifs importants
ils sont pas saluées et surtout du vélo
aussi mis ce week-end la gestion donc le
protêt les tonga sont cellerino qu'il va
faire un concert c'est difficile de
convaincre des artistes de venir ici à
saint quentin en yvelines pour faire
mais pour faire écoutez moi j'étais pas
dans le dans le projet mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui lui est venue parce que
c'était pour le téléthon donc c'était
une oeuvre caritative et ça il a tout de
suite dit oui je crois qu'il est aussi
fan de vélo en fait donc
le couple et ont permis de deux familles
qui viennent le concert aura lieu à 21h
samedi soir et j'avais tout le monde à
venir en fait voir ce concert ça sera la
première fois il ya dieu m'a conseillé
en fait de dj aujourd'hui sa première
fois avec un concert avec des
instruments dans une configuration faire
venir les artistes est justement à les
faire s'éloigner un petit peu de paris
parce qu'il a sorti son habitude de
voyager en banlieue et en région
parisienne en fatiha ils le font ils
vont un peu partout dans des petits
théâtres
non là on peut leur procurer un théâtre
enfin un espace beaucoup plus grand en
fait donc c'est vraiment intéressant
et justement par rapport à voilà aux
événements de paris qui sont passés donc
les attentats ce qu'il ya des meilleurs
de confortement de sécurité qui vont
être mises en place
ça va être compliqué elle n'a pas ça
complique l'achat de la tâche savons que
les coups ça c'est clair mais c'est
important pour protéger notre public
aujourd'hui et tout est en place on a
derrière déjà rajouté des bars y est on
a des contrôles on a des contrôles avec
ed pour vérifier le métal sur les
personnes des fouilles de l'epad et
fouille visuelle de sacs et si besoin en
fait des palpations pour les gens en
fait tout est respecté la loi en fait
mais on était en relation avec la
préfecture avec les autorités de police
locales donc là tout est en place et
aujourd'hui pour les actuels du téléthon
et dans une semaine pour l'accueil du
noël du vélodrome
c'est clair que tout en place et les
gens peuvent être assurés à venir d'eux
sans problème vous savez combien de
temps un peu pour rendre attractif le
vélodrome deux ans pour avant eux
bah oui j'espère que d'ici deux ans on
puisse enfin avoir des choses des
événements récurrents des c'est ça qui
est important en fait c'est de pouvoir
satisfaire des fédérations de la fevad
la fédération de cyclisme l'a fait les
fédérations sportives autres et les
artistes pour que ils prennent
l'habitude de dire voilà quand on va
faire un championnat de france un
championnat d'europe on vient par défaut
on peut venir ici parce qu'on sait que
c'est l'accueil sera intéressant et pour
les artistes quand ils vont établir une
tournée ou bien faire des répétitions ce
type de choses mais voilà cette salle là
existe elle est plutôt agréable et on
peut venir assez facilement ici en fait
et en plus la population répond et vient
de façon à ce que c'est aussi important
c'est qu'à population
découvre ce lieu et envie de venir en
fait on peut se garer facilement des
possibilités est donc aussi des
transports en commun voilà une dernière
question d'heures avant de nous quitter
est-ce qu'il ya quand même une pression
que ce serait que ça va coûter de
l'argent j'avais une pression
aujourd'hui est vraiment un oui à la une
des leçons de résultats aujourd'hui on
est contraint de mettre le maximum de
moyens pour faire en sorte que
simplement ces bâtiments vivait avec eux
il puisse procurer du plaisir à toutes
les personnes qui vont venir voir des
des compétitions sportives ou des
spectacles
merci beaucoup jarod avoir répondu à
notre question et je le rappelle les
deux événements de cette fin d'année
donc c'est le téléthon au vélodrome avec
et des animations de vendredi jusqu'à ce
dimanche prochain mais aussi le 12 et 13
décembre
un week-end dédié à noël pour les
enfants et nous restons à présent dans
le sport mais nous quittons le vélodrome
pour parler de rugby chaque jeudi vous
en avez l'habitude maintenant c'est la
chronique sport avec les mutuelles et
demi d'euros j'ai bien installé michael
je viens d'installer mon soir vous allez
viens on sort flou et je sais vous à
doha le rugby les percées balle en main
les mêlées acharnée les plaquages en
pleine course et bien j'en ai tenu
compte aujourd'hui dans ma chronique du
jour coup de projecteur sur un contre de
fédérale 3 seniors chevreuse contrecoup
ya un match programmé ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade municipal de la ville
pour nous parler de cet événement nous
recevons sur ce plateau le coach des
trois-quarts des chevrotin stéphane
boucher bonsoir alors vous affichez à
l'heure actuelle un bilan de quatre
défaites deux victoires en six matches
disputés cette saison
est ce qu'on peut dire que la victoire
est impérative ce dimanche impérative
impératif pas forcément on
on n'a pas les mêmes ambitions qu'un
club comme rouille
ces deux villes différentes oui c'est un
effet une grande ville c'est un club qui
est plus huppés logiquement cno nous on
n'est pas une grande ville en est une
belle ville alors on est aussi un beau
club et ce qu'on veut nous c'est en
effet comme vous ai dit la dernière fois
on veut se reconstruire
alors je préfère une guy roux je peux
vous dire qu'on veut prévenu que voit on
des jeux depuis tous les dimanches on
veut gagner on va faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour gagner ce dimanche là et puis
bon bain puisque on va jouer contre eux
ou y
oui ça risque de faire mal en effet
voilà on va faire ce qu'il faut et
comment allez-vous faire justement pour
gagner cette rencontre
alors pour gagner pour gagner ce match
là bas
en général il faut marquer plus de
points que l'adversaire donc non on va
faire ce qu'il faut c'est à dire que on
va continuer à développer notre jeu
actuellement et donc on produit beaucoup
de jeu on a des qualités aussi bien
devant derrière
ça demande plus de liant sa demande ce
qu'on concrétise nos actions et puis
quand on est un peu plus la tête sur les
épaules de temps en temps qu'on gère
correctement nos temps forts et nos
temps faibles et met donc on invite en
effet tout le monde à venir dimanche
pour une rencontre intéressante dans
l'est dans le département voilà une
belle ville un château à visiter donc
jeu parfait sur le papier bah oui quand
on aura gagné ce sera parfait et au
niveau d'éducation vous êtes allé à
l'heure actuel avant dernier du
championnat ils sont quatrièmes est ce
que vous êtes
outsider sur cette rencontre vraiment
être ailleurs avant on va jouer le petit
poucet vais te dire normalement on est
les pauvres petits poucets mais il faut
pas oublier qu'on a un match deux mois
tous les clubs se tiennent là on est
cinq cycles moi-même sept clubs à se
tenir en pas beaucoup de points du tout
ça peut tourner très vite et ce match
sera vous l'avez dit un derby illinois
est ce qu'on prépare un petit peu
différemment ce derby vinoy au niveau de
la préparation du match alors là celui
ci non non parce que moi avec ouille
il n'y a pas un historique particulier
avec ouille
il ya d'autres clubs oui mais bon de
toute façon un match avec un club de la
région parisienne
en effet c'est toujours un petit peu
particulier mais bon en général ça donne
des populations n'est pas forcément plus
importante sur ce type de match la
motivation est toujours très importante
dans notre équipe
toujours très importante et au niveau du
coût de vos objectifs cette saison ce
sera le maintien quoi qu'il arrive le
monde divisé a quand même un petit peu
plus haut nous pensons mais
on pense que le maintien c'est pas un
objectif en soi
pour nous on est persuadé avec tous les
matches qu'on a fait depuis demain à un
moment on sait que notre notre place en
fédérale 3 est obligatoire par contre on
sait qu'on peut faire bien mieux que ça
et évidemment on veut jouer la
qualification va jouer la qualification
et on fait tout pour y arriver et ça
passera par une victoire contre louis ix
ce dimanche il faudra prendre des points
contre eux vous y allez prendre
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
le match entre chevaux et où est
programmée ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade municipal de chevreuse et vous
passez à présent un sport où les rebonds
sont moins quatre questions qu'au rugby
je veux bien sûr parler trappe reçoit ce
samedi à 20 heures le club de val de
seine dans son gymnase paul mallet pour
le compte de la 8ème journée de
nationale 3 les hommes coachés par
mustapha el hafidi sont à l'heure
actuelle dans le bas du classement après
leur défaite du week-end dernier contre
juvisy 66 à 58 les ide ne sont et ne
seront donc pas favori contre les
deuxièmes du championnat mais ils
pourront compter sur leur pivot joey
casseus pour l'emporter
rendez vous samedi à 20 heures pour les
soutenir florum et on termine à cette
chronique par un défi un peu fou
programmé au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un oui florane
à un pari fou le pisteur de vélizy 78
jean michel richefort va relever le défi
de rouler pendant 24 heures sur la piste
du vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines pour le téléthon l'exploit
est programmée entre ce vendredi 4
décembre à 18 heures et ce samedi 5
décembre à 18 heures le sportif sera
accompagné de pistard professionnels et
amateurs qui vont se relayer sur la
piste pour l'aider à tenir la distance
au total de cyclistes de vélizy devrait
réaliser environ 650 km pendant la durée
du défi à chaque tour de piste jean
michel richefort collectera 20 centimes
d'euros en faveur du téléthon merci
amitié vous allez accompagner jean
michel arrive fort sur la piste du
vélodrome de 50 ans et viennent n'ont
malheureusement je vais le regarder
depuis les tribunes je vais laisser les
professionnels réalisé le tour de piste
eh bien merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine donc on vous retrouve comme à
chaque jeudi pour la chronique mais pas
de 7,8 sport ce lundi il sera remplacé
par un 7,8 politique henri en raison des
élections régionales mais que les
téléspectateurs se rassurent on vous
retrouvera mardi à 10h30 à 18h30 voilà
on nous parlerons automobile et du jeune
prodige de cartes williams bertrand il
sera également question de floorball
pipeline venus de suède florame merci
michael et maintenant place au portrait
du jour il s'appelle gwendal il a 17 ans
il va se lancer dans un des concours les
plus reconnus le meilleur apprenti de
france il a déjà remporté déjà deux
épreuves et participera à la finale
nationale lundi 7 décembre qui verra
s'affronter les dix meilleurs jeunes de
l'année en alternance au restaurant la
ferme deux voisins il est épaulé dans sa
préparation par son maître
d'apprentissage
romain geek el fani bourdillon la
rencontrer pour nous alors super trois
couverts jetables affaire à trois jours
à trois pieds de l'ops aignan et ans
baissait à 1 barnas une tatin vous
plaire il est 12h30 et en cuisine à la
ferme de voisins tout le monde s'active
au milieu des chefs renommés gwendal 17
ans est concentrée en alternance ici
depuis trois ans il suit rigoureusement
les instructions de son maître
d'apprentissage
alors comme ça on est hélas pas cotées
comme ça gentiment en choeur c'est s'il
vous plaît iginla nous quand on
rencontre les jeunes il vient toujours
faire un deux trois jours de stage dans
l'entreprise afin de voir si eux ça leur
plaît et si nous y colle au profil
également wendat l'on a tous senti qu'il
était passionné par ce qu'il faisait et
qu'il avait envie d'apprendre
si à l'envi derrière on peut faire de
belles choses ensemble
à 15 heures l'équipe a en pause avant de
revenir quelques heures plus tard pour
le service du soir
mais pour gwendal et son maître cuisiner
pas de répit ils préparent ensemble le
prestigieux concours du meilleur
apprenti de france
c'est un concours qui se divise en trois
parties il ya d'abord une partie sur la
planification régionale
c'est une finale régionale qui mois pour
moi était dans l'île de france ensuite
il y avait la demi finale nationale et
le
j'en fus à la finale la grande finale se
jouera ce lundi 7 décembre où les dix
meilleurs apprentis de france
s'affronteront dans une épreuve de 4h30
pour faire face à cette très grande
confiance
il faut savoir garder la tête froide
aujourd'hui sont hissés en finale dix
parmi les 24 meilleurs qui avaient été
sélectionnés sur toute la france donc ce
sont dix à pouvoir gagner la finale
il faut travailler c'est un concours
c'est une épreuve d'un jour quand même
ça peut arriver de brûler un produit
développé une sauce de renverser quelque
chose c'est très dur un concours à sa
perte et fois très très violent sur la
première c'était assez dur à gérer le
stress tout ça c'est bon mais se fait
derrière moi donc ça m'a ça m'a aidé
pour pour y aller une finale que gwendal
aborde aujourd'hui avec sérénité
ils visent déjà le titre très convoité
de meilleur ouvrier de france et c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de nous
avoir suivis demain vous avez rendez
vous avec wilfrid enrichi pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal avec
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
quant à moi je vous retrouve lundi je
vous souhaite donc une bonne soirée et
un excellent week end